[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans les
matins du sénat nous allons suivre
l'audition de luc lallemand c'est le
nouveau pdg de sncf réseau il est
auditionné par la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable du sénat le pdg
qui reviendra notamment et qui
s'expliquera sur la manière dont sncf
réseau a géré cette crise du coronavirus
et il reviendra également sur les
inquiétudes que sucitent l'après crise
concernant notamment l'entretien et la
rénovation du réseau ferroviaire ou
encore l'avenir des petites lignes
on va donc tout de suite regardé
l'audition du pdg de la sncf réseau bien
mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer notre audition qui je le
rappelle est en partie en présentiel et
en partie en en visioconférence donc on
aura tout à l'heure des questions qui
seront posées par les sénateurs présents
et puis par des sénateurs qui à distance
ont manifesté ou manifesteront le
souhait d'interroger notre invité qui
est monsieur luc lallemand président
directeur général de sncf réseau sommes
très heureux de vous accueillir sur le
président vous avez pris vos fonctions
le 1er mars dernier nous avions prévu de
vous auditionné une date très proche de
prise de fonction et pour des raisons
qu'il n'est pas besoin de rappeler nous
avons dû évidemment décaler cette cette
audition sommes d'autant plus heureux de
vous auditionné que malheureusement le
parlement a été récemment privé du droit
qui l'avait d'auditionner le président
de sncf réseau préalablement à sa
nomination comme c'était le cas depuis
2010 nous avons eu l'occasion d'exprimer
des regrets mêmes et même davantage je
le dis même si naturellement vous n'y
êtes pour rien elle nous aimerions vous
poser bien sûr au cours de cette
audition et vous entendre sur un certain
nombre de sujets premier sujet
évidemment très important c'est la
trajectoire financière de sncf réseau je
rappelle que l'état a prévu une reprise
de la dette des snf réseau à hauteur de
35 milliards que 25 milliards ont déjà
été repris dans le cadre de la loi de
finances pour 2020
que les 10 milliards restants devraient
être repris dans le cadre de la loi de
finances pour 2022
l'objectif de cette reprise de la dette
est d'alléger les charges financières de
la sncf ou de la sncf réseau pour que
sncf réseau athènes des réseaux fine des
ratios pardon compatible avec sa
transformation en société anonyme est
l'objectif de ce mécanisme conjuguée à
des efforts de productivité mais aussi à
l'application de la règle d'or et
qu'est-ce ncf réseau atteigne
l'équilibré en 2024
la crise du que vides 19 a évidemment
entraîné un certain nombre de
conséquences financières sur lesquelles
nous espérons que vous pourrez nous
donner un certain nombre d'éléments est
ce que vous avez pu d'ores et déjà
évalué les conséquences financières de
cette crise comment comptez-vous faire
face à ses conséquences financières est
ce que vous comptez demandé à l'êta de
de vous aider à couvrir les surcoûts
étant entendu qu évidemment nous ne
souhaiterions pas que cette situation
conduisent à ne pas remettre comme
c'était prévu notre réseau à niveau car
il en a vu le démenti est certainement
pas bien bien besoin
le secrétaire d'état jean baptiste
djebbari que nous avons auditionné il ya
quelques semaines nous indiquer que les
pertes se répercuterait sur le contrat
performance qui doit ou qui devait je ne
sais pas ce que je dois dire être signé
avant l'été 2020 et donc pour savoir si
je dois employer le présent le passé
vous me direz où en est ou en sont les
négociations par rapport à ceux à ce
contrat le secrétaire d'état nous avait
également indiqué qu'en raison de la
crise
vous devriez revoir votre calendrier et
la priorisation des travaux nous avait
indiqué dans un récent courrier que vous
nous avez adressé que les travaux de
régénération avait repris et qu'ils
étaient je croire planifier jusqu'en
décembre 2020 nous aimerions
puissiez nous en dira davantage que vous
puissiez également nous dira si les 3,6
milliards que là l'homme a prévu
d'injecter chaque année dans le réseau
6e si ce chiffre de 3 6 milliards est
toujours d'actualité et notamment en ce
qui concerne un sujet sur lequel nous
sommes évidemment très vigilant dans
cette enceinte et au delà
c'est la question des petites lignes
deuxième sujet très important pour nous
c'est la question du fret et de sa
survie
la crise du que vides 19 n'a pas arrangé
la situation du fret
elle a en revanche confirmé le caractère
indispensable du fret dont la part
modale n'a fait que diminuer au cours
des années alors sncf réseau est bien
sûr un rôle très important puisque c'est
vous qui
répartissez les décrets les les cherche
le terme exact
non je sais pas sa voix porte les
capacités je cherchais le terme
technique mais didier vend des livres
des sillons voilà merci locaux les
sillons entre les voyageurs et le fret
et donc vous avez évidemment un rôle
très important à jouer d'autant plus que
ce qui est souvent reproché au fret
ferroviaire c'est le manque de
ponctualité une ponctualité qui est tout
à fait essentiel pour pour ses clients
donc je nous aimerions également que
vous puissiez nous dire quels sont vos
projets par rapport au fret pour que le
fret ne soit plus une simple variable
d'ajustement par rapport à l'attribution
des sillons dernière dernier élément ce
qui me concerne mais je suis certain que
didier mandelli complétera et mes
collègues aussi nous aimerions savoir où
en est sncf réseau de la préparation de
l'ouverture à la concurrence et
notamment de la question de
l'indépendance des sncf réseau par
rapport à la société mère là aussi nous
avons eu à exprimer un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes par rapport aux
ordonnances qui ont été prises sur la
gouvernance des inquiétudes qui ont été
évoquées avant nous par l'art à faire et
nous avons nous même repris à notre
compte ces inquiétudes puisque
évidemment
le l'ouverture à la concurrence ne peut
pas se faire s'il n'y a pas une réelle
indépendance des différentes sociétés
sncf réseau par rapport à la société
mère voilà quelques-uns des points que
je voulais évoquer en introduction je
laisse le président la parole puis
didier mandelli interviendra ainsi que
tous mes collègues ici présents ou ici
en ligne qui le souhaitent
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
tout d'abord je souhaiterais vous dire à
quel point je suis heureux d'être parmi
vous cet après midi je suis ravi que ma
première intervention devant la
représentation nationale se fasse au
sein de la chambre des territoires qui
est particulièrement attentive aux défis
et aux enjeux que souhaite relever sncf
réseau j'ai pris mes fonctions de
président directeur général de sncf
frizot le 1er mars dernier
mon audition devant votre assemblée
était initialement prévue début avril
mais n'a malheureusement pas pu se tenir
en raison de la crise que nous
traversons et avant d'entrer dans le vif
du sujet je souhaiterais brièvement me
présenter à vous et puis je procéderai
une intervention liminaire de 15 minutes
environ
je suis ingénieur commercial de
formation et titulaire d'un diplôme
d'officier pont de la marine marchande
j'ai rejoint la sncb qui à l'époque
était là la petite soeur en cif au moins
grand de la sncf ou en 1991 1 j'ai
occupé différentes fonctions avant d'en
être le directeur financier pendant
trois ans
et puis au moment de la scission de la
sncb en trois entreprises séparées
j'ai fondé et dirigé le gestionnaire
d'infrastructure ferroviaire belge
infrabel
et ce pendant plus de 15 ans en
parallèle j'ai été administrateur de
réseau ferré de france de 2007 à 2015 et
de ratp dev de 2011 à 2020 ce qui m'a
permis de me familiariser au secteur des
transports en france
alors tout d'abord je souhaiterais vous
exposer la manière avec laquelle sncf
réseau a géré la crise sanitaire
depuis le début de l'épidémie kovy 19
sncf réseau a été guidé par deux
préoccupations fondamentales
la première c'est de garantir la
sécurité sanitaire de ses salariés de
ses clients ainsi que de l'ensemble des
intervenants dans ses activités et la
deuxième c'est de répondre aux besoins
évolutifs des clients c'est dans ce
cadre que nos activités ont pu être
organisés en trois priorités d'une part
assurer le niveau de maintenance
nécessaires du réseau pour garantir la
circulation dans la durée pendant et au
delà de la période de confinement
ensuite c'est la sueur et la gestion du
trafic des trains de voyageurs et de
fret trains qui ont été maintenus sur
tous les trains fret pendant la crise et
troisièmement c'est de reprendre très
progressivement les chantiers
d'investissement après une phase d'arrêt
survenue suite à la mise en place du
confinement de la population pour
assurer la continuité de
l'approvisionnement et de la vie
économique sur le territoire sncf réseau
a donné une priorité absolue au trafic
de fret
il s'agissait en effet d'assurer
l'approvisionnement des entreprises et
de la population
je pense par exemple au transport massif
de carburant de produits alimentaires de
matériel militaire de produits liés à
l'industrie chimique ou pharmaceutique
chaque jour pendant la période de
confinement environ 700 trains de fret
ont circulé sur le réseau
c'est peu connu soit près de 70 70 %
pardon des trains de fret d'une journée
ordinaire important à noter c'est que la
baisse du volume a été liée à la
réduction de la demande et pas comme ça
a été parfois 10 à la difficulté de
satisfaire cette demande la tenue à la
bonne gestion des postes d'aiguillage et
des centraux sous-stations ce sont les
centres qui gère l'alimentation
électrique de la caténaire fondamental
pour le trafic est indispensable à la
circulation des fameux train sanitaire
des trains de voyageurs
de fret et de ce fait la très large
majorité du réseau est donc restée
ouverte avec souvent évidemment des
adaptations horaire pourtant dans
certaines régions sncf réseau a dû faire
face à une diminution significative des
agents disponibles au delà de
l'entretien du réseau exploité qui a pu
se poursuivre sncf réseau a dû constater
l'arrêt de l'essentiel des chantiers
d'investissement dans quelques cas parce
que ces chantiers empêcher la priorité à
la circulation des trains de fret mais
surtout dans la grande majorité des cas
du fait de l'arrêt de l'ensemble du
secteur des travaux publics
au début du confinement la sncf réseau à
veiller à un arrêt maîtriser des
différents chantiers pour permettre leur
sécurisation et faciliter les conditions
de reprise cet arrêt des chantiers a été
commun à l'ensemble du secteur btp et il
a fait l'objet d'un travail entre l'état
et les fédérations professionnelles avec
les principaux maîtres d'ouvragé pour
définir les modalités de travail qui
permette la reprise de l'activité avait
toujours une priorité en ligne de mire
c'est de garantir la sécurité sanitaire
des salariés ce travail a abouti au
début du mois d'avril à la publication
d'un guide de l'organisme professionnel
de prévention du btp qui a été validé
par les ministères de la santé et du
travail
l'ensemble de ces mesures de protection
sanitaire a permis une reprise
progressive des chantiers
l'investissement dès le début du mois
d'avril
certains chantiers prioritaires avaient
redémarré
je pense au fameux talus deux sèvres et
de la mi avril
nous avions repris plusieurs très grands
projets tels que le redémarrage des
travaux du tunnelier dans le chantier
école le 21 avril dernier
on peut dire à ce jour que 7 85% des
chantiers d'investissement ont redémarré
et que 100% des chantiers aura redémarré
fin juin au plus tard
rien n'aurait pu se réaliser sans
l'engagement et la mobilisation forte
des cheminots qui ont été au rendez vous
j'ai pu le constater une nouvelle fois
dans mon expérience du secteur
ferroviaire
les cheminots font un travail admirable
souvent méconnus qu'il gèle à pierre
fendre
ou par canicule les femmes et les hommes
du rail travaille à l'amélioration du
réseau ils sont profondément attachés à
leur outil de travail
ça a été vrai que ce soit pour la
maintenant essentiel du réseau ou pour
l'organisation exceptionnelle des trains
sanitaires ou encore pour assurer une
continuité du transport de marchandises
grâce en particulier aux aurait restée
aux aiguilleurs comme l'a indiqué le
président du groupe jean pierre farandou
la force du groupe sncf c'est d'être un
groupe d'utilité publique d'autant plus
en période de crise les cheminots font
preuve d'un engagement et d'une
mobilisation sans faille
j'en viens maintenant monsieur le
président à la situation économique et
financière de la sncf réseau et à ce qui
peut constituer après trois mois à la
tête de sncf réseau dont deux mois et
demi en gestion crise que 8,19 à ce qui
peut constituer un petit peu mon rapport
d'étonnement sans conteste le rail
français est un des plus beaux outils de
mobilité au monde et je sais à quel
point les françaises et les français
aiment leur chemin de fer le chemin de
fer fait partie du patrimoine de leur
patrimoine national le réseau ferré
français est le deuxième réseau européen
après les réseaux allemands il est
composé de plus de quarante six mille
kilomètres de voies je vais interrompre
une seconde on signale dans le fond de
la salle qu'on ne vous entend pas très
bien qu'il aurait que vous redresser le
micro plus vers vous comme ça voilà
j'espère que ça ira mieux
mais monsieur bignon vous pouvez aussi
vous rapprochez vous avez le droit de
vous rapprocher les imf le président
donc je crois que ça ira mieux comme
comme ça j'étais un peu trop loin du
micro de toutes les excuses 2600 km de
lignes à grande vitesse un ski qui sont
vraiment un outil tout à fait
remarquable et puis ce réseau français
il a trois grandes spécificités
la première c'est sa taille très étendue
je pense aux quinze mille 400 passages à
niveau je pense à plus de 132 mille
ouvrages d'art je pense aux 2200 postes
d'aiguillage pour une deuxième grande
caractéristique c'est sa vétusté
avec un âge moyen de la voix de 30 ans
de la caténaire de près de 40 ans les
appareils de voies près de 29 ans et
l'âge moyen des appareils de
signalisation se situe autour de 26 ans
donc
l'âge moyen des composants du réseau est
assez important et puis la troisième
caractéristique de notre réseau c'est la
diversité des trafics
le trafic est en effet très polarisé
entre des zones très saturé évidemment
l'ile-de-france en premier lieu et puis
des zones où le trafic est nettement
plus faible
les efforts consentis par les
gouvernements depuis 2012 ont permis de
stabiliser la tendance au vieillissement
pour la voix mais pas pour les autres
composants du réseau
donc il s'agit bien d'une stabilisation
hélas pas d'une amélioration
le retard important accumulé depuis 30
ans sera long à résorber
il requiert des efforts importants et
durables malgré les efforts du pacte
ferroviaire pacte ferroviaire qui a
permis de de ré intensifier les montants
affectés à la régénération un audit
indépendant sur le réseau français qui a
été réalisé il ya trois ans par une
équipe d'experts internationaux inquiète
une une spin-off de l'école
polytechnique de lausanne a permis
d'objectiver toutes ces données fondée
sur le constat de la poursuite du
vieillissement du réseau français et de
l'entraidé ligne
grande vitesse de première génération
dans le cycle de rénovation le rapport
de l'école polytechnique de lausanne
recommandé une augmentation progressive
du budget de rénovation à 3,5 milliards
d'euros par an contre 2,8 à 2,9 pour
l'instant l'effort indispensable de
régénération et de modernisation du
réseau s'inscrit dans un nouveau cadre
économique et financier en effet le 1er
janvier dernier
l'entreprise est devenue une société
anonyme et en parallèle avec ceux la
sncf réseau doit ramener les cash flow à
l'équilibré à l'horizon 2024
pour mémoire le quatrième de sncf réseau
en 2019 s'élevaient autour des 2
milliards d'euros
cet objectif qui est véritablement
existentielle pour la société non
seulement vis-à-vis de l'état non
seulement vis à vis du groupe sncf cet
objectif vis-à-vis du groupe sncf qui a
lui-même engagé dans un processus de
redressement de ses comptes et
l'objectif est tout aussi essentielle
vis-à-vis des parties prenantes et
vis-à-vis des collaborateurs pour éviter
tout accident à l'avenir l' équilibre
financier
attention il ne s'agit pas de faire du
profit on parle d' équilibre financier
qui est indispensable à la viabilité
d'une société anonyme comme dans une
famille j'oserais dire comme dans une
famille la totalité des dépenses ne peut
pas excéder la totalité des recettes
pour atteindre cet équilibre nous sncf
réseau nous devons d'abord montrer
l'exemple de la frugalité
nous allons réaliser un programme de
près de 1,6 milliard d'euros sur dix ans
en économie de coûts et aux gains de
productivité étant entendu que
productivité ne veut pas dire travailler
plus mais veut dire que chaque heure
prestée et plus productive
par une organisation efficace de l'outil
industriel ensuite l'état intervient
avec un désendettement de près de 35
milliards d'euros
et avec le recyclage dans le réseau des
dix fils d'un des dividendes reçus du
groupe sncf qui sont hélas suite à la
crise que vivent 19 en très forte
diminution donc l'équation est simple à
poser un petit peu plus difficile à
résoudre
il ya d'une part une exigence de retour
à l'équilibré financier
et puis d'autre part un retard important
de rénovation à combler à cela
s'ajoutent de nouvelles normes dont nous
ne contestons pas le bien fondé mais que
nous devons absorbé dans le conte s'agit
par exemple de l'annnonce de la fin du
glyphosate d'ici fin 2021 et des
conséquences de la loi 10 10 sur la
prise en charge des ouvrages d'art et
des conséquences de la grève de la
réforme afférentes à la réforme des
retraites
et puis last but not least le choc
coville était particulièrement difficile
pour pour sncf réseau qui avis qui a vu
ses recettes de péage fortement diminué
et a dû faire face au surcoût des
travaux liés aux mesures prises dans le
cadre du contexte sanitaire le futur
contrat de performance entre l'état et
sncf réseau est donc crucial son enjeu
sera de parvenir à conjuguer une
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibré avec
un niveau ambitieux de régénération du
réseau
en effet les besoins de rénovation vont
croissant les lignes à grande vitesse
doivent être rénovés la rénovation doit
être étendu à la signalisation les
caténaires et les ouvrages d'art je
souhaiterais accélérer la
rationalisation de l'outil industriel
pour faire du réseau français un fleuron
européen
concrètement engagé une réduction du
nombre de postes d'aiguillage par la
création de grands centres de commande
centralisé d'une part et d'autre part
réduire significativement le nombre
d'appareils de voix aiguillages
traversée jonction double
enfin le contrat de performance devra
éclairer l'avenir des lignes de desserte
fine du territoire
aujourd'hui sncf résout entretien 100 %
du réseau mais ne peut pas rénové 100 %
du réseau le cadre de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités peut nous
permettre de repenser notre relation
partenariale avec les régions sur ce
sujet enfin je ne peux terminer mon
propos monsieur le président sans
évoquer un éventuel plan de relance pour
le ferroviaire
il convient de distinguer deux enjeux
bien distants d'une part le premier de
pouvoir préserver les investissements
prévus au pacte ferroviaire et d'autre
part le second est d'identifier à
quelles conditions
pourrait-on faire plus si l'état décide
d'un plan de relance fondé sur des
objectifs de soutien à l'activité et de
baisse des émissions de co2 certes
l'infrastructure n'est pas une activité
de court terme
en revanche elle a des effets
multiplicateurs notamment en termes de
soutien à la filière industrielle par
ailleurs le train une double vertu ils
économisent l'espace et l'économie de la
ressource
il représente 10 % du transport de
voyageurs et de marchandises mais
seulement 1,6 pour cent des
consommations d'énergie et 0,6 pour cent
des émissions de co2 des transports
je relayais ainsi la préside la demande
du président du groupe jean pierre
farandou de donner au ferroviaire toute
sa place dans le monde des nouvelles
mobilités et de doper sa capacité
d'investissement
monsieur le président le train est un
moyen de transport fabuleux la france
dispose d'un phénoménal actifs
ferroviaires et de cheminots passionné
et très engagé
le train peut projeter notre pays
résolument dans la transition écologique
elle peut ainsi continuer à démontrer
que la france reste un des meilleurs
endroits pour vivre sur la planète tous
ensemble soutenons le ferroviaire
je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les membres de
la commission pour votre attention et me
tiens à votre disposition pour toutes
vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vais tout de suite donné la parole à
didier mandelli que les référents sur
les questions de transport ferroviaire
dans notre commission merci monsieur le
président monsieur p dg de 7 cf réseau
va bondir faux socios derniers propos
nous sommes évidemment prêts ici un
commission soutenir le ferroviaire
nous avons pu le démontrer au travers
des travaux de la commission et des
différentes positions qui ont été menées
jusqu'à ce jour
jusqu'à cette audition qui permet de
vous permettre de poser de vous poser
quatre questions précisément la première
concerne le fret ferroviaire vous avez
évoqué le chiffre de 70 % pour la mise
en oeuvre des transports pendant le
confinement des entreprises signalent
effectivement que les cncf réseau a pu
très bien travailler assuré 95% des
plans de transport
donc c'est à souligner mais en même
temps ça démontre que jusqu'à présent ça
n'était pas le cas et notre crainte
c'est que cette situation ne retrouve
son son lit d'avant je serais tenté de
dire puisque lalanne ont circulé si la
non circulation des trains de transport
de voyageurs et l'arrêt d'un cerveau de
travaux a permis effectivement le
fluidifier et d'améliorer la desserte
ferroviaire
la moyenne de circulation est en
générale prévue à hauteur de 100
kilomètres/heure et on sait que c'est en
général plutôt proche de 30 km heure en
moyenne sur sur le fret donc notre notre
souci c'est vraiment que le fret prenne
toute sa place et que les sillons puisse
être prioritaire également sur sur ce
volet de tanger une parenthèse mais que
si si demain nous avons quelques trains
de nuit ce que beaucoup souhaitent
il faudra aussi faire cohabiter ces deux
types de transport la deuxième question
elle porte sur les vous l'avez évoqué
également le présent d'évoquer sur la
conclusion du contrat pluriannuel entre
la filiale de sncf réseau chargé de la
gestion des gares et l'état et comment
ce contrat va t'il s'articuler avec le
contrat de performance
entre cncf réseau et les termes
troisième question concernant les
petites lignes ferroviaires vous avez
fait référence à l'homme est là la
possibilité pour les régions désormais
de s'engager sur sur ses lignes en tout
cas en terme de rénovation
le ministre nous avait présenté des
plans d'action régionaux en février en
tout cas pour deux régions dans un
premier temps avec des investissements
qui avaient été estimées une époque
autour de 7 milliards d'euros
qu'en est il aujourd'hui et quels sont
les montants qui seront effectivement
investis par sncf réseau aux côtés des
régions éventuellement sur ces petites
lignes
dernière question elle fait référence à
n'être que vous adressé récemment la
présidente de la région ile de france
madame pécresse selon lesquelles sncf
réseau privilégierait les travaux du g
express au détriment des travaux de
rénovation des rer b et d
est-ce que c'est avéré ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur ce
point et nous indiquer comment les
arbitrages d'ailleurs son sont rendus en
matière de de priorisation des chantiers
voilà pour l'essentiel je crois que mes
collègues auront beaucoup de question
également de côté
merci je vais donner la parole à michel
vaspart puis à martine filleul puisque
je devais aspar et rapporteur de la
mission d'information sur la
compétitivité des ports et martine
filleul en est président de cette
mission
et puis ensuite vous pourrez répondre à
cette série de trois questions avant que
je ne redonne à nouveau la parole à
d'autres collègues
monsieur vaspart merci monsieur le
président monsieur présente sncf réseau
oui ma collègue martine filleul
président une mission dont je suis
rapporteur qui est notamment une mission
qui s'intéresse aux grands ports
français au grand port maritime en
général nous avons eu l'occasion d'aller
dans tous les grands ports français
depuis maintenant le mois de décembre
dernier nous sommes également allés à
rotterdam nous sommes allés en verre il
nous a manqué pour des raisons que qui
ont été évoqués tout à l'heure un
déplacement à gênes
et nous voulions d'une part voir quels
étaient les les raisons qui faisaient
que nos grands-parents gros grands ports
maritimes français prenait du retard ont
pris du retard et continuer à prendre du
retard sur le fret international par
rapport à un certain nombre d'autres
grands ports européens dont notamment
comme je vous le disais anvers rotterdam
qui était près du havre mais également
le pirée gêne et même trimestre donc ce
sont des des ports qui nous entoure on
parle moins de barcelone et nous avons
effectivement eu énormément
d'informations qu'elles soient des
informations qui nous viennent de
belgique où que ce soit les informations
qu'on a pu récolter sur le territoire
national au travers nos auditions mais
également les visites que nous avons pu
faire grand port veut dire intermodalité
s'il n'y a pas d'interdît
d'intermodalité équilibré et bien
évidemment nous avons nous continuons
engagé les routes donc l'intermodalité
c'est le fus fluvial et le ferroviaire
nous avons la chance en france d'avoir
un des très grands port céréalier
d'europe qui rouen selon la rochelle
aussi mais nous avons rouen et nous
avons eu une surprise extrêmes lorsque
nous avons auditionné et visité le port
de rouen
c'est qui nous a été signalé que
aujourd'hui l'acheminement des céréales
depuis les silos qui sont en campagne et
qui sont desservis par des capillaires
les capillaires et et sont en très
mauvais état
personnes actuellement n'envisage de les
rénover et aujourd'hui nous en sommes à
entendre lors de nos auditions et de nos
visites que le transport qui se fait
aujourd'hui par voie ferrée risque
d'être transférés par la route tellement
les capillaires sont en mauvais état
donc vous imaginez que notre commission
il a été particulier particulièrement
sensibles car ça va à l'encontre
de tout ce qu'on peut faire en matière
de déquilibre d'intermodalité est
également de lutte contre le co2 et
l'engorgement de nos routes
l'engorgement de nos routes nous a été
signalé dans beaucoup de grands ports
français
1 nous sommes très en deçà en matière
d'intermodalité ferroviaire au départ
des grands ports de ce qui se fait dans
les pays voisins
donc monsieur le président il ya un réel
problème
nous ne pouvons pas envisager qu'il y
ait du fret actuellement transportées
par le faire qu'ils soient transportés
demain par la route
ce serait véritablement un scandale 1 je
ne parle pas du fluvial parce que c'est
vous n'êtes pas directement concernés
mais c'est un vrai sujet et je reste à
voir quels sont les moyens actuellement
que vous allez consacré que vous
consacrez que vous allez consacrés à la
rénovation de ces capillaire qui dessert
les ports céréaliers français
merci monsieur va se parler monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président de
sncf réseau je ne voudrais pas répéter
mal ce cas fort bien dit monsieur valls
par le rapporteur de la mission
peut-être et effectivement aller dans
son sens en disant que nous avons
constaté au cours de notre périple le
manque de connexion des ports avec le
rail et avec les fleurs
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans d'autres
pays européens et tout particulièrement
dans les pays du nord à amsterdam
rotterdam mais j'allais dire qu'il y a
un vrai problème d'infrastructures et il
est vraiment urgent de se pencher sur ce
problème d'infrastructures mais au delà
des investissements se pose également la
question de la qualité du service rendu
aux chargeurs et aux entreprises
ferroviaires par sncf ce réseau nous
avons entendu parler d'une nécessité de
faciliter la fluidité et la qualité du
service
par exemple en termes d'applications
numériques de suivi en direct
d'amélioration de la procédure de
commande de six longs ou encore
d'optimisation du prêt construit est-ce
que vous avez effectivement le projet
d'avancer dans ce sens merci beaucoup
merci d'un film se présente je vous
propose de répondre à cette première
série de questions éventuellement si
vous pouviez répondre à quelques-unes
des questions que j'ai posées auxquelles
je n'ai peu réponse j'en serai très
heureux mais si vous ne le faites pas je
suis certain que monsieur jacques 1 va
va reprendre mais question donc de toute
manière vous n'y couperez pas c'est le
président tout d'abord sur le fret
ferroviaire donc je sur le fret
ferroviaire dans le micro s'il vous
plaît là aussi là encore on me fait
signe sur le fret ferrovaire je pense
qu'il convient de distinguer deux grands
sujets le premier sujet le sujet des
investissements
et puis l'autre sujet et le sujet des
pistes d'amélioration de la qualité du
service pour le fret alors sur les
investissements on est dans un contexte
où on a on a de lourdes opérations de
régénération qui sont en cours sur les
axes structurants du réseau et qui sont
programmés évidemment sur sur plusieurs
années et qui servent tant les intérêts
des clients du fret que les intérêts
dans le secteur voyageurs alors ces
propositions qui émerge de la demande du
relance du fret ferroviaire
ce sont avant tout en réalité des
projets d accélération de projets
d'investissements qui ont déjà été
identifiés alors le point critique là
dedans et est malheureusement avec le
ferroviaire c'est souvent le cas le
point critique c'est le financement
on est suspendu à la condition de
pouvoir les produire en termes de
ressources financières de travaux et
sous la réserve aussi parce que c'est
pas toujours uniquement une question d'
euro qui ne réduisent pas la capacité
commerciale qui revendiquait par les
clients par d'autres clients et ses
investissement nécessite également un
financement spécifique dans certains cas
que compte tenu de la situation
financière de sncf réseau on ne peut
malheureusement pas assumer alors la
voie de l'espoir je pense qu'ils étaient
en cours sur lesquels il ya des
discussions qui ont été initiés pour
l'instant avec l'état c'est de pouvoir
inscrire une partie de ses démarches
dans le cadre d'un plan de soutien ou de
relance post coït 19 sur les pistes
d'amélioration de la qualité du service
qui est le deuxième volet pour le fret
mais on ya plusieurs pistes qui sont
soit déjà pratiqué soit explorée on à la
généralisation à l'ensemble des grands
axes fret une planification à cinq ans
de la répartition des différents usages
de la capacité
on a le fret et les voyageurs on a aussi
les travaux qui qui
consomment de la capacité est donc cette
répartition dans un sens qui préserve
une capacité suffisante pour répondre
aux besoins des marchés du fret
je pense qu'aujourd'hui tous les
interlocuteurs du fret s'exprime non
seulement en termes d'investissement
mais aussi en termes de qualité du
sillon alors un autre exemple c'est la
mise en oeuvre de mesures qui visent à
préserver cette capacité autant que
possible jusqu'au jour de la circulation
évoluer vers un système de réservation
de la capacité qui assurerait une
disponibilité d'une certaine réserve
pour des commandes de fred tardive parce
que la gestion de l'infrastructure pas
seulement en france mais sur toute
l'europe est organisée avec une
périodicité qui est planifiée très très
longtemps en avance un an voire un an et
demi donc pour satisfaire les demandes
je dirais de dernière minute ça nous
semble important de pouvoir réserver une
capacité qu'on peut servir jusqu'au jour
de circulation pour évoluer vers un
système qui offre aux clients du fret
qui le souhaitent la possibilité de
réserver une forme de capacité
pluriannuel simplifier la procédure
d'autorisation de transport exceptionnel
voire même réduire les cas de figure
concernés par ces autorisations
là il ya des démarches qui sont en cours
pour l'instant dans la société
réduire la fréquence de survenance de
situations dans lesquelles deux branches
d'un itinéraire alternatif sont en fait
indispensable pour des circulations
commerciales où je pense encore à les
investissements pour poursuivre la
digitalisation des outils de gestion de
la capacité et de l'exploitation ça on a
une démarche qui est en cours et
d'ailleurs de nouveaux applicatifs qui
sont qui sont vraiment en cours de non
pas de développement mais
d'implémentation pour l'instant en ce
qui concerne la deuxième question sur
l'articulation des contrats de
performance mais là je dois je dois vous
confesser que vu la crise du coc vide
19/20 on a pris un sérieux retard par
rapport au calendrier initial
fin février début mars on était je
dirais animé par l'espoir de pouvoir
clôturer voir signer ces contrats de
performance e fin avril début mai au
plus tard bien sûr vous vous en doutez
les 10 11 dernières semaines ont été
essentiellement consacré à la gestion de
cette de cette crise très grave et nous
devons maintenant je dirais d'abord
arrêté les compteurs ce qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas encore fait à l'heure où
je vous parle arrêté les compteurs de la
nouvelle situation financière en ce qui
me concerne pour sncf réseau mais bien
entendu vu que sncf réseau s'inscrit
dans une dans une logique de groupe et
de consolidation sncf réseau est un
contributeur ou un poil selon la
perspective avec laquelle vous le
regardez où un point important dans les
finances du groupe sncf
et là on est en train de finaliser je
dirais la situation post co vide afin de
pouvoir rentrer avec les différents
ministres et ministères concernés dans
une discussion sur cette nouvelle
situation financière je dirais de des 0
et puis de voir compte tenu de cette
nouvelle situation financière très
dégradée
comment est-ce que ces contrats de
performance pourrait s'articuler
comment est ce qu'on arrive à un
équilibre ambitieux mais réalisable
ambitieux mais réalisable entre d'une
part les moyens qui seront consacrés au
secteur et d'autre part ce que le
secteur peut apporter en terme de deux
fonctionnalités de mobilité pour la
nation donc sur le sujet contrat de
performance on est on est en réalité
avec la crise du coc vite on est plutôt
au tout début des discussions sur la
troisième question qui concerne les
lignes de desserte fine du territoire
nous savons que c'est un sujet très
difficile il ya il ya plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres de lignes
de desserte fine du territoire qui sont
enfin qui tombe dans les fameuses
catégorie i ses sept à neuf c'est à dire
les lignes les moins parcouru du pays
je suis très conscient que c'était un
sujet monsieur le président que vous
même et votre commission allait examiner
et suivait de près c'est un sujet
difficile aussi parce qu'évidemment au
niveau des scènes cf réseau notre notre
ambition et notre rêve c'est de cette
que la totalité du réseau les 33 milles
900 km de lignes vous être parfaitement
opérables et un niveau de qualité
acceptable pour la clientèle il ya un
certain nombre d'initiatives
particulière qui ont été prises par par
le ministre des transports monsieur jean
baptiste djebbari on est occupé pour
l'instant à regarder avec avec lui avec
le ministère comment est ce qu'on va
mettre ça en oeuvre dans dans le nouveau
contexte en sachant bien sûr que si on
souhaite maintenir
je lui dis au cours de mon introduction
si on souhaite maintenir les 33 milles
900 km de lignes qui représentent près
de 50 mille kilomètres de voies dans le
pays est bien un manque ablement il
faudra se reposer la question du
financement
et puis votre quatrième question
concernant la lettre de madame la
présidente pécresse sur le le cdg
express
mais là ma réponse elle est à ses
excuses et pardonnez moi l'expression
mais légaliste je pense que le projet
cdg express est un projet qui étaient
décidées avec lequel nous avons une
convention avec l'état
et là dedans cncf réseau souhaite tout
simplement remplir ses engagements
contractuels
je dirais c'est pas parce qu'il ya eu la
crise que nous avons connue que il y a
lieu de modifier la vue que nous avons
sur ce projet il ya une convention
existante chacun sait très bien ce qu'il
a à faire et dans quel délai et sncf
réseau souhaite exécuter intégralement
la convention qui a été
qui a été signé alors par rapport à
votre vos questions monsieur mesure à
spa sur la question de l'intermodalité
on en est pleinement conscient
bien sûr la question d'assurer la
mobilité dans l'hinterland par rapport
aux au grand port c'est une question
fondamentale pour le pour le ferroviaire
vous avez cité en particulier
l'importance de l'acheminement des
céréales au départ des capillaires j'en
suis pleinement conscient parce que j'ai
eu l'occasion de me rendre compte à quel
point ce que vous venez d'exposer une
est une réalité fondamentale du réseau
français pendant la crise qu'ovide 19
on était particulièrement attentif on a
eu des comités exécutifs tous les jours
et au sein de des discussions dans ces
comités exécutifs très régulièrement est
revenu la préoccupation des céréaliers
en effet et de l'alimentation par les
capillaires du réseau principal pour le
transport de céréales donc nous y sommes
très très attentif ce qui ne veut pas
dire que s'il n'y aura pas l'une ou
l'autre difficultés opérationnelles mais
en tout cas sur mon expérience des dix
mains de covile 19
on a eu des retours je dois dire plus
qu'encourageants et même des
félicitations de la part des
intervenants dans ce circuit céréaliers
sur les efforts qui ont été faits sur
les réseaux français pour pouvoir
acheminer ces transport céréalier est
alors madame filleul par rapport à votre
question sur l'application notamment du
suivi numérique et des sillons donc
simplement vous dire à quel point je
trouve que le numérique et la
digitalisation de l'entreprise
incroyablement important dans mon
ancienne vie j'ai mené de très nombreux
projets dans dans le numérique
pour le gestionnaire des infrastructures
ferroviaires belges
je souhaite mener la même dynamique par
rapport à par rapport au réseau français
par rapport à sncf réseau mais cette
numérisation n'a pas attendu mon arrivée
en toute humilité il ya déjà un certain
nombre de projets très importants comme
le sip h qui sont en cours pour
l'instant qu'ils sont en pleine
déclinaison notamment au niveau de la
gestion numérique et de digitaliser des
sillons donc nous sommes sur cette voie
en tout cas ce qu il faut bien dire
quand on est dans un projet de numériser
de numérisation part donc d'une
entreprise c'est qu'il peut y avoir des
maladies de jeunesse
donc nous sommes résolument sur une
stratégie numérique que je souhaite
encore intensifiée au sein d'ailleurs
d'une stratégie numérique pour le groupe
sncf et donc les efforts en cours non
seulement ne vont pas être relâchés mais
vont même être intensifiées au cours des
prochaines années
plus globalement je pense que les
transports en commun en général et donc
en particulier le ferroviaire ont
vraiment un très grand intérêt
stratégique à être les fers de lance des
technologies numériques
parce que les technologies numériques
pour le client conçoit en bitossi ou
qu'on soit orbite hobby les technologies
numériques pour le client permettent à
la fois de mieux utiliser le produit
parce que ça permet de rentabiliser
entre idiot mais le temps pour le client
passé à bord et quand il s'agit plus
spécifiquement des clients fret
le fait de numériser tous nos produits
c'est à dire la vendée sion mais aussi
tous les autres produits qu'on offre en
parallèle à l'avant des sillons ça
permet de réaliser au niveau de notre
clientèle des gains de productivité et
aussi de simplifier l'accès aux produits
ferroviaires qui j'en conviens n'est pas
toujours le plus le plus simple à vendre
voici monsieur le président quelques
premiers éléments de réponse merci
monsieur le président je vais donner la
parole à monsieur chevrollier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de sncf réseau je salue tout
d'abord votre ambition pour sncf réseau
de devenir un fleuron européen s était
un projet qui a du sens et je voudrais
le souligner est également saluée comme
vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs dans votre
propos salué l'engagement de vos
collaborateurs pendant la période de
crise sanitaire
alors justement cette crise sanitaire
est ce que le le qu'ovide l'aco vide va
faire dérailler le plan
d'investissements dans le réseau
alors que et vous en avait parlé il ya
cet enjeu extrêmement fort de la la
régénération du réseau
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes enfin dans
ma région en particulier sur sur les
investissements sur l'entretien dans les
petites lignes avec si l'augmentation du
coût et des délais donc il y à ce qui
était prévu et il y à ce qui pourrait
être vu dans le cadre d'un plan de
relance des investissements dans le
ferroviaire qui n'est pas encore
d'actualité nous dans notre commission
aménagement du territoire et
développement durable
on met en avant très fortement et notion
d'éco conditionnalité ou et un soutien
qu'est ce que vous pourriez mettre en
avant en face d'un investissement
supplémentaire dans le ferroviaire vous
avez déjà évoqué le terme de la
transition écologique est ce que vous
pouvez développer un certain nombre de
points pour appuyer votre votre demande
j'aurai une autre question sur la les
1,6 milliard d'économies
générés dans le cadre une amélioration
de la productivité avec une meilleure
organisation
quels impacts sociaux cela induira et
notamment par rapport à une autre
inquiétude est un autre débat qui a lieu
actuellement aujourd'hui au sénat sur le
l'emploi des jeunes sur le recrutement
de jeunes dans votre institution et
dernier point un sujet qui fait du bruit
ce sont les nuisances sonores des lignes
à grande vitesse
quelle est votre approche sur sur ce
sujet où on a encore beaucoup de
remontées sur le terrain merci merci ce
chevalier monsieur longeau merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président merci pour vos propos et merci
pour vos explications
un parcours vos explications aux
intéressés que elles sont claires et
france mais elle nous laisse un grand
doute parce que effectivement entre la
réalité et le rêve
je crois qu'il y a
pire qu'un fossé c'est celui
effectivement des financements et ça
nous inquiète parce que nous avait
répondu exactement la même chose que
nous a répondu jean pierre farandou la
dizaine de jours sur l'entretien des
voies en disant qu'on n'a pas pu le
faire pendant le période du coc vite
parce que il n'y avait pas d'entreprise
après on ne peut pas trop le faire parce
qu'effectivement il ya de la circulation
mais moi je me pose une véritable
question et c'est est-ce que ça c'est
bien la réalité celle de ne pas pouvoir
le faire à certains moments où est ce
que la réalité c'est derrière le manque
de financement et ce qui pose un vrai
problème c'est que nous sommes tous ici
convaincu 1 que le fret d'important et
notamment dans la lutte contre les
effets de gaz à effet de serre mais
aujourd'hui est ce que on peut vraiment
performant à partir du moment où nous
aurons un réseau qui manquera
d'entretien et vous l'avez dit parce que
c'est pas de puits la semaine dernière
qui manque d'entretien ça fait des
années et des années et qu'elle entre le
montant qu'il faudrait pour investir
chaque année est le montant que l'on
investit il ya là aussi un fossé et bien
sûr vous avez proposé de faire des
économies mais je ne suis pas sûr que
tout cela permettra de financer des
réseaux qui nous permettrons
effectivement d'avoir un fret qui soit
un frais de qualité un fred qui
répondent aux attentes des utilisateurs
et je voudrais pas qu'on donc dans ce
que disait tout à l'heure michel ces
deux effectivement à un moment donné de
remplacer le fret par mettre des camions
sur l'ensemble des routes parce que on
n'aurait pas pu avoir les
investissements nécessaires
alors je sais que ma question est pas
simple si elle est simple la question ce
qui est plus compliqué c'est la réponse
j'ajoute qu'à nom de monsieur longeau
j'ai oublié de le dire tout à l'heure
notre commission mettra en place une
mission d'information justement sur
l'avenir du fret ferroviaire
monsieur jacques 1 n'oubliez pas de
rappeler mes questions vous êtes là pour
ça oui je vais le faire monsieur le
président et je vous remercie d'avoir
organisé cette audition mais j'aimerais
qu'effectivement sur certains points on
est des réponses plus précises
monsieur le président l'allemande c'est
votre première rencontre avec le
parlement alors que vous portez une des
infrastructures essentielles de la
nation est ce que je viens d'entendre
c'est une découverte de la situation
française très peu critique
moi j'aurais aimé de vous un regard d un
rapport d'étonnement
puis un vrai regard neuf comme vous
pourriez le le poser et vous semblez là
pour l'instant observé en tout cas vous
présentez comme ça qu'en est-il de
réorganisation à venir à sncf réseau par
exemple vous procédez manière très
différente que celle du président de la
holding de tête monsieur farandou qui
est comment dire plus plus rapide dans
ses décisions de réorganisation comme on
l'a vu est une des questions auxquelles
vous n'avez pas répondu aux questions
non présidence et l'indépendance de sncf
réseau sachez messieurs l'allemand qu
pendant le pas les discussions du pacte
ferroviaire certains et dans cette salle
avait dit il faut une muraille de chine
entre sncf réseau et les opérateurs pour
permettre l'ouverture à la concurrence à
la question de l'indépendance de la sncf
réseau vous n'avez pas répondu
vous avez répondu d'une manière qui
m'inquiète
lorsque vous vous avez évoqué à la
deuxième question le contrat de
performance en disant que c'est une ces
réseaux appartient une logique de groupe
et donc il faut équilibrer les choses
financièrement on peut prendre les
choses de deux manières mais en termes
d'indépendance ça ça m'inquiète
et ça m'inquiète au moment où non
seulement monsieur farandou a pris en
main est très fortement sncf mais sa
férule
je la qualifie comme ça est
particulièrement dense votre
prédécesseur en sait quelque chose
alors sur le contrat de performance on a
progressé un tout petit peu vous nous
avez dit qu'on était au début des
discussions que tout est revu avec la
crise ducobu tout le monde comprend la
crise du code vide et il n'y a plus
beaucoup de programmes qui tiennent à
cause de la crise ducobu n'empêche que
par la loi or vous êtes arrivé en mars
mais dès le 1er janvier 2020 et le
parlement
on aurait dû avoir la présentation de ce
contrat de performance et monsieur
djebbari nous a dit lors de sa dernière
audition qu'on l'aurait cet été mais
vous nous dites que on est tout au début
dé des discussions mon collègue vient de
vous reposer la question du financement
des petites lignes
vous nous avez dit que par votre nom
réponses que vous n'aviez pas la
solution malheureusement et c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet complexe
donc je vous repose cette question là
est la question du président sur les + 3
milliards de travaux qui était prévu
comment vont être t-il être reprogrammé
ça intéresse le parlement ça intéresse
la nation et moi je ne veux pas me
contenter de poser des questions sans
avoir de réponse comment ces auditions
moi je resterai
je resterai chez moi ou alors je
déposerai par écrit ou peut-être que
c'est une solution sur la tarification
des décisions c'est un tout petit peu
évoquée c'est une question très complexe
on attend le prochain document de
référence réseau qui portera la
tarification pour trois années 2000 21
alors on est parti dans une logique de
segmentation du réseau des tarifications
et département des paiements
proportionnelle au trafic et à sa
rentabilité n'entretenons pas là dans
une logique je vais la comparer à la
tarification à l'acte à l'hôpital vous
allez me dire pourquoi je fais ce
parallèle là on a décidé un jour de tous
comptabilisés à l'hôpital puis on arrive
un jour à ne plus avoir la vision
globale et un réseau ferroviaire unique
qui doit fonctionner avec un principe de
péréquation interne quand on commence à
tout découpé et bien je fais ce
parallèle dans ce moment tragique avec
la situation du coc vide avec la logique
économique qui a prévalu à l'hôpital
malheureusement je termine vous avez
répondu à la question des trains du
quotidien de mon collègue didier
mandelli sur l'arbitrage charles de
gauche charles de gaulle express et rer
b vous avez répondu obligations
contractuelles alors que sur d'autres
dossiers vous nous dites que vides
on revoit tout mais là moi je constate
que le l'arbitrage final qui est rendu
c'est en faveur des contres
et en faveur du charles de gaulle
express qui est très loin des trains du
quotidien sur le fret ferroviaire
moi j'ai proposé la gratuité pour 2020
et elle était en cours de discussion
après la crise des grèves liées aux
retraites
la fra et certains opérateurs la demande
pour 2020 est gelée demandé dans un
amendement
si vous l'obtenez bercy en tiendra-t-il
compte dans votre contrat de performance
et je termine j'étais trop long sur
l'hommage que vous avez rendu au
personnel l'hommage chaleureux est
nécessaire il faut le dire mais y
aura-t-il des primes qu'ovide la sncf je
vous remercie
merci monsieur jacques un jeu présent je
vous propose de répondre à cette série
deux de trois questions
j'ai encore deux séries de trois
questions après donc voilà je vous
laisse répondre à celle ci merci
monsieur le président alors tout d'abord
la question de la première question de
monsieur chevrollier concernant que
mettre en avant pour justifier un
investissement supplémentaire
en fait on est on est dans une situation
où
les enveloppes telles qu'elles sont
programmés aujourd'hui pour la
régénération ne sont pas suffisantes
pour maintenir la totalité des
techniques ferroviaires en état de
stabilisation on a une stabilisation
pour la technique voix qui est
évidemment en termes de sécurité
une des plus importantes avec la
signalisation donc une stabilisation
voire une légère amélioration concernant
les deux autres techniques ferroviaires
que sont la caténaire et les courants
forts d'une part et d'autre part la ceni
la signalisation les enveloppes actuels
du contrat performance ne permettent pas
de stabiliser la situation ça veut dire
qu'on continue sur ces deux techniques
la à se dégrader et surtout aussi si je
pensais la signalisation
ça ne permet malheureusement pas
d'engager le réseau ferroviaire national
français
danse
[Musique]
un investissement systématique dans les
nouveaux systèmes de signalisation ertms
et tcs mais je tiens à fortement nuancer
ce propos en disant que comme la france
a été au début des années 80
véritablement pionnière dans dans
l'invention et la mise au point du tgv
est là fort logiquement développer des
systèmes de signalisation qui n'étaient
plus des systèmes de signalisation
latéral mais embarqué en france ça
s'appelle la tvm avec une première
version et puis après il ya eu d'autres
versions notamment la tvm 430 et la tvm
donc le système actuel de signalisation
pour le tgv français a les mêmes
fonctionnalités que la signalisation
européenne la seule différence avec les
tcs et réalisations européennes s'étant
fait que ce dernier système européen lui
il est interprétable là où la tvm
française n'est pas un terreau opérable
il faut toujours faire attention de bien
nuancer les choses sur le domaine
signalisation il ya en effet leur
enveloppe qui ne permet pas de
stabiliser le demain de la signalisation
ça se dégrade un petit peu on peut pas
faire les tcs mais ne pas faire les tcs
est beaucoup moins grave que dans que
dans d'autres pays parce que le réseau
tgv est équipé d'un système de
signalisation à la base qui était déjà
très performant et donc quand on est
dans une situation pareille et qu'on est
con propose le cas échéant dans une
discussion qui a démarré de faire un
investissement supplémentaire
la difficulté de la discussion c'est que
c'est pas pour faire plus c'est pour
empêcher la dégradation et pour
permettre de maintenir ce qu'on appelle
dans le système ferroviaire la substance
du réseau c'est à dire qu'il faut à un
certain niveau de il faut un certain
montant annuel d'investissement pour la
maintenance et le renouvellement pour
maintenir le niveau et si on n'est pas à
ce niveau là il ya une perte de
substance et cette perte de substance à
un moment donné il faut décider si on
décide de la récupérer ou bien si on la
récupère
pas quels sont les pertes de
fonctionnalités sur le réseau donc que
mettre en avant
j'essaye d'apporter une réponse précise
à votre question que mettre en avant
pour justifier un investissement
supplémentaire
c'est tout simplement de maintenir les
fonctionnalités actuelles voire de les
améliorer
dans un contexte de décors de
décarbonation d'être des transports et
de l'économie en france
deuxième question que vous avez posé
c'est sur l'impact social des économies
de 1,6 milliard d'euros ainsi que
l'impact potentiel sur le recrutement
des jeunes
alors dans ce milliard 6 de requêtes un
montant cumulé sur dix ans il y a une
très grande partie plus de la moitié
dans le programme qui est quiconque qui
consiste à réaliser des économies de
coûts tu qui ne concerne pas le
personnel c'est-à-dire une par exemple
une meilleure relation partenariale avec
nos partenaires industriels ou pense
plus aux lifecycle cost notamment des
installations et ou par un partenariat
plus solide entre les fournisseurs et
sncf réseau on parvient à réaliser des
économies sur la chaîne de valeurs
industrielles après pour l'impact social
potentiel nous n'irons pas plus vite que
ce que permet la pyramide des âges et
les départs naturels
je pense que jean pierre farandou l'a
indiqué à plusieurs reprises
l'emploi est la préoccupation du social
dans le groupe sncf reste une des
préoccupations numéro un et donc nous
allons organiser ses programmes en
manière telle que je dirais ça ne
dépasse pas le rythme naturel des
départs de la société ensuite en ce qui
concerne le recrutement des jeunes
on pardonne et moi j'ai pas les chiffres
encore en tête mais il ya des
recrutements extrêmement important en
nombre qui continuent à être effectuées
et je dirais que la difficulté qu'on a
c'est plutôt de les trouver dans des
métiers qui sont fort demandé les
métiers de l'ingénierie les métiers
techniques de les trouver épouse d'avoir
la capacité de formation plutôt que d'en
en fait avoir le pied sur la de
frein
donc pour le recrutement des jeunes je
suis très optimiste nous allons
continuer à sncf réseau et je peux même
vous dire pour la totalité du groupe
sncf
nous allons continuer à recruter
massivement des jeunes et en particulier
dans tous les métiers techniques pour
votre question sur la nuisent les
nuisances sonores sur les lgv
je vous présente mes excuses c'est un
sujet que je n'ai pas encore pu
documenter et donc plutôt que de vous
donner des éléments qui ne serait pas
prêt si je me permettrai monsieur le
président c'est possible et c'est susi
salle usage de votre commission d'y
répondre
audi répondre par écrit alors concernant
les questions de monsieur nous jouons jo
longeau longeau excusez moi excusez moi
peut-on être performant avec un rezzouki
qui manque d'entretien
mais je dirais que c'est tout c'est
toute la discussion que nous aurons avec
l'état dans le cadre du contrat de
performance
en réalité je crois que l'on peut
formuler l'équation comme ça il ya les
deux extrêmes adéquation et puis entre
les deux extrêmes autant de nuances de
gris
la première extrême celle à laquelle on
rêve qui est la plus favorable pour le
réseau c'est con atteignent des montants
de régénération qui permettent de
maintenir la totalité du réseau français
dans l'état où il est voire d'améliorer
puisqu'on a pris un certain retard voire
d'améliorer l'état du réseau
ça nécessite un effort financier qui
n'est pas négligeable
il faut qu'on ait des discussions
approfondies avec l'état là dessus qu'on
parvienne à le convaincre que c'est
nécessaire et puis l'autre partie je
dirait l'autre extrême
c'est de renverser le raisonnement est
de dire on part avec une certain
enveloppe qui est capé qui est limité et
puis à l'intérieur de cette enveloppe
comment est-ce qu'on devrait privilégier
par quel levier ou par quelles priorités
ce qu'on devrait privilégier le
développement du réseau
hélas si vous regardez le plan
stratégique notamment qui était en cours
au niveau de sncf réseau ben tout temps
de perdants absolument pas de vue
l'importance des lignes de desserte fine
du territoire
il ya tout de même une priorité à ce que
l'argent du contribuable soit orientée
sur le réseau qui est le plus parcouru
alors entre les deux comme je disais il
ya autant de nuances de gris
mais vous connaissez vous connaissez les
montants qui sont nécessaires pour
pouvoir au minimum stabiliser ce qui le
présente une différence de l'ordre de
600 à 700 millions d'euros par rapport à
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui et toute la
question est de savoir où va se situer
finalement l'arbitrage final
alors vous avez parlé de performance
mais je sais que le sujet de de la
libéralisation et de l'ouverture à de
nouveaux clients et de nouveaux
opérateurs est un sujet qui est une
grande préoccupation de votre commission
monsieur le président qui est aussi une
grande préoccupation de sncf réseau
parce qu'il est clair qu'un réseau qui
est plus parcourus avec un plus grand
nombre d'opérateurs est un réseau qui
est mieux rentabiliser
donc évidemment aussi du point de vue du
réseau ou plus ya 2 trains qui
parcourent ce réseau au plus on dispose
de moyens pour l'entretenir est pour et
pour l'améliorer donc la question de la
maintenance du réseau et son bon
entretien
c'est aussi une question stratégique
dans la libéralisation on observe dans
sur les grands réseaux en europe et pas
que d'ailleurs que la libéralisation a
bien fonctionné notamment sur les
réseaux qui ont été bien entretenu c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
pardonnez moi c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'avoir d'organiser une
compétition d'attirer de nouveaux
clients sur un réseau qui est dégradée
donc ce n'est pas seulement un enjeu
performance pour nous c'est aussi un
enjeu de pouvoir attirer potentiellement
de nouveaux clients ou de mieux
satisfaire les clients existants qu'ils
appartiennent au groupe sncf où qu'il
soit en dehors du groupe sncf
alors concernant les questions de
monsieur jacques 1 et la prolongation de
vocations monsieur le président je ne
les ai pas oubliés vous me demander des
réponses plus précises donc je vais
faire un effort particulier notamment
sur le rapport d'étonnement est plus
critique qui serait attendu
ben tout d'abord je tiens à vous dire
que je je suis pas critique pour le
plaisir d'être critique
je pense que le secteur ferroviaire pas
seulement qu'en france mais un peu
partout en europe est un secteur qui est
passionnant notamment parce qu'il touche
à toutes les dimensions de la vie
sociale économique politique dans un
pays et donc c'est aussi un secteur ou
un peu partout en europe il y à une
interaction extrêmement forte évidemment
avec le avec la décision politique avec
les élus qui ont la légitimité suprême
de décision
mon rapport d'étonnement mais pour leur
libellé avec d'autres mots c'est un
c'est un réseau je dirais à deux voire
trois visages
il ya ce réseau tgv qui et qui fait
l'admiration
j'espère à l'intérieur du pays mais
aussi à l'extérieur qui étend qui est en
très bon état mais comme je les dis dans
mon introduction les lignes des plus
ancienne elle date du début des années
80 je pense notamment à paris lyon
donc il y a là un effort qui va devoir
être faits comme le restant du réseau
pour les maintenir correctement mais
donc le réseau lgv
je pense qu'il est qu'il est très
performant
après on a ce qu'on appelle les huits
ces deux assises donc c'est le réseau
structurant sur lesquels sur certaines
lignes de gros efforts à faire et qui
sont en cours
il ya notamment la technique des suites
rapides qui a été mise en oeuvre et qui
est observé avec là aussi beaucoup
d'attention par beaucoup d'autres
réseaux étrangers qui consiste à
régénérer certains tronçons de lignes au
certains ligne de manière de manière
accélérée
donc il ya ce deuxième réseau qui
étaient en cours deux générations qui
est le réseau structurant et qui
concerne ce qu'on appelle les trains
d'équilibré du territoire qui sont
extrêmement important dans un pays qui a
une géographie et une taille qui se
prêtent extraordinairement bien au train
parce que le train est fort entre entre
quelques kilomètres jusque jusqu'à 1200
200 kilomètres donc ce pays est vraiment
le pays du train au niveau de sa taille
et de sa forme
et puis un troisième réseau sur lequel
un manque ablement je suis un peu plus
critiques quant à son étincelle eux le
réseau de lignes de desserte fine du
territoire
il a il ya un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui ont été prises par le
ministre conviendra maintenant de voir
dans le conte dans le cadre du contrat
de performance et notamment les montants
qui seront consacrés en financement bac
l avenir est ce qu'on peut donner à
cette à cette partie là du réseau donc
peut-être pas un rapport critique mais
en tout cas un rapport d'étonnement sûr
je dirais un réseau que je pourrais
qualifier de réseaux aux trois visages
la question de l'indépendance de sncf
réseau alors là tout d'abord pour moi
c'est extrêmement simple à un moment
donné le parlement d'un pays
l'assemblée nationale vote des lois et
nous je dirais qu'ils sont nous en toute
humilité pour
pour faire autre chose donc il ya un
système de normes juridiques qui a été
qui a été voté avec les derniers textes
qui ont été publiés le 31 décembre
je crois que c'est le 31 décembre que
les que les derniers textes ont été on
ne sait pas si ça va voter ou publié que
je dois dire pardonnez moi c'était
imprécisions mais en tout cas moi je
suis légaliste
donc on est dans un système où l'état
français a souhaité mettre en place un
groupe sncf intégré auquel appartient
sncf réseau comme société anonyme dans
la société anonyme sncf réseau je dirais
par différenciation des autres sociétés
anonymes
il ya tout de même un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
pour garantir non seulement
l'indépendance des fonctions
essentielles que sont la tarification
d'infrastructures et l'attribution des
sillons mais aussi un certain nombre
d'autres choses par exemple une
protection particulière en matière de
décisions d'investissement et puis il y
allait pouvoir qui ont été conférés à la
rt régulateur très très puissant un bien
plus puissant que ce que j'ai pu voir
dans d'autres pays et qui a notamment
son mot à dire puisque j'ai dû présenter
une épreuve fin janvier auprès de de la
rt qui a son mot à dire sur la
nomination et sur la révocation du
président directeur général de sncf
réseau donc je vous répète je suis
légaliste
nous nous en tiendrons au texte les
textes tous les textes et que les textes
malheur au delà de ça si vous me le
permettez monsieur le président je
voudrais donc partager un élément de
réflexion avec vous sur cette fameuse
organisation ferroviaire qui fait couler
beaucoup d'encre et énormément de
polémiques dans toute l'europe déjà
depuis les premières directives de
libéralisation
ou en tout cas de séparation du réseau
et du restant des opérations depuis
quatre vingt dix sous 91 si mes
souvenirs sont bons la première
directive européenne
j'ai eu l'occasion dans mon ancienne vie
de vivre dans deux systèmes
d'organisation en 15 ans pendant les
neuf premières années j'étais dirigeant
du gestionnaire d'infrastructure dans un
système de holding où il y avait une
holding gestionnaire d'infrastructure et
puis un opérateur ferroviaire
et puis le gouvernement belge de
l'époque en 2013 a considéré que le
système dysfonctionnel
parce qu'il y avait pas mal de conflits
essentiellement entre la holding et
l'opérateur ferroviaire
deuxièmement que la holding était une
structure extrêmement coûteuses qui ne
rapportaient pas beaucoup de valeur
ajoutée et donc le gouvernement à
l'époque souhaité simplifier ce modèle
est donc à partir du 1er janvier 2014
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de mon ancienne
vie j'étais dans un modèle où j'étais
totalement indépendant plus de sociétés
holdings au dessus et dans un système
qui rapportait directement au ministre
d'être où je rapportais directement
ministre des transports ce que je vois
aujourd'hui dans le fonctionnement du
groupe sncf nouveau système depuis trois
mois c'est que ce système a permis de
bien faire fonctionner le très haut
niveau d'intimité qui existent
d'intimité technologique qui existe dans
les chemins de fer entre la partie
infrastructure et ce qui bouge donc le
train j'ai l'occasion de commencer ma
mon parcours professionnel comme
officier de marine métier que je n'ai
pas fait longtemps mais suffisamment
longtemps pour constater que le degré
d'intimité technologique entre un navire
et les bords qu'ils fréquentent
il est très bas ce niveau d'intimité
c'est juste le tirant d'eau et deux
trois éléments de communication radio
idem pour le secteur routier où le
niveau finalement 2-2 d'intimité
technologique entre les deux est
relativement faible dans le rail il est
extraordinairement importants et
complexes en plus et donc je pense j'ai
la conviction personnelle que le modèle
qui a été finalement choisi par la
france
permettra de marier l'eau et le feu
c'est à dire d'une part d'avoir un
grande un excellent niveau de
collaboration et de concertation qui est
requis à cause de cette zone au niveau
de deux d'intimité technologique entre
l'infrastructure et ceux qui roulent
d'une part et d'autre part maintenir
l'ambition de libéraliser le secteur est
d'attirer de nouveaux opérateurs et dès
aujourd'hui sncf réseau a tout de même
40 de clients sur ses rails c'est pas
négligeable alors je reconnais que c'est
moins que l'allemagne mais comparé à de
nombreux autres pays européens peut tout
de même dire que la france est assez
avancé dans la libéralisation de son
système de transport ferroviaire et même
au delà de transport public et donc
peut-être pour tout de même vous
rassurer sur cette indépendance
moi j'ai l'intention d'exercer les
prérogatives qui me sont confiées par le
système de gouvernance ferroviaire
française de les exercer de manière
professionnelle
c'est à dire en étant attentif à toutes
les dispositions de droit qui me sont
applicables sans en oublier auquel vous
avez évoqué le sujet que je souhaite
préciser parce que j'ai bien utilisé le
terme de consolidation financière avec
la société mère est pas l'imitation
possible de la société mère dans des
décisions d'investissement de sncf
réseau donc je pense que cette nuance
est très importante
j'ai parlé de consolidation financière
puisque sncf réseau fait partie du
groupe public unifié
il ya des obligations de droit financier
de droit économique qui s'applique je
dirais de manière naturelle et
automatique comme ça s'impliquerait dans
n'importe quel groupe d'entreprises les
le capital de sncf réseau en vertu de la
loi est à 100 % détenue par sncf maison
mère et donc il est non seulement
logique mais aussi simplement légal que
sncf réseau soit consolidée dans je
dirais le le bilan consolidé de la
société mère et c'est à ce titre que
j'ai voulu dire que les pertes que nous
avons réalisé malheureusement dans la
crise qu vite plus le fait que même
après reprise de la dette en deux étapes
le cash flow de sncf réseau va rester
très négatif si nous ne faisons rien à
l'horizon 2024
si nous ne faisons rien de manière
automatique
cette déficit de cash flow seront
consolidées avec le cash-flow consolidé
de la maison mère et aussi avec la dette
consolidée de de la maison sève votre
troisième question sur comment est ce
que vont être reprogrammé les travaux
suite à la crise que vit la réponse est
simple l'exécution est plus compliqué la
première réponse que je voulais vous
faire c'est que l'intention du conseil
d'administration et du management c'est
évidemment de mettre en oeuvre
d'exécuter tout le budget 2020 d'un tel
qu'il a été voté par le conseil en
novembre décembre et nous faisons pour
l'instant l'impossible avec toutes les
équipes de terrain pour reprogrammer les
travaux qui ont dû être déprogrammée
pendant ces deux mois
et là le sujet je dirais pour une fois
profitons-en pour une fois le sujet
n'est pas financier ou économique
c'est plus un sujet de disponibilité des
des voix puisque nous souhaitons
évidemment accorder la priorité d'abord
au client final que le client soit
voyageurs ou qu'ils soient fret et donc
sncf réseau elle pour la capacité
qu'elle mange sur le réseau pour
réaliser ces travaux doit programmer sa
très longtemps à l avance et ça c'est le
handicap dans lequel nous nous étions
pour l'instant en toute humilité c'est
un c'est un sujet vraiment complexe sur
le plan opérationnel
c'est que nous avons perdu des sillons
d'un slot en masse pendant ces deux mois
avec main parfois des week-ends
prolongés vous savez que les week-ends
prolongés sont pour nous
systématiquement je dirais l'occasion de
réaliser
des travaux qui nécessitent plus que
deux jours à être réalisés donc pour les
slot l'est pour les sillons qui ont été
perdues sur des périodes difficiles à
reprogrammer
nous sommes en discussion pour l'instant
avec nos clients parce qu'évidemment
nous ne pouvons pas faire ça d'autorité
nous devons nous concerter avec nos
clients pour voir pour reprogrammer des
périodes auxquels ils seront déranger le
moins le moins possible alors je partage
tout à fait votre analyse que vous avez
fait en quatrième point de votre
intervention
et la comparaison que vous faites avec
le monde hospitalier quand on commence à
tout découper un moment donné
effectivement on ne voit plus la
finalité la finalité de ce qu'on fait
tout est une question d'équilibré
en chemin de fer sncf réseau en bonne
intelligence a eu avec le restant du
groupe va être extraordinairement
attentive à la question des territoires
et donc même s'il est clair que en
économie des transports
quand on affecte un heureux au chemin de
fer
et bien c'est le mieux c'est qu'il
profite aux au plus grand nombre de
contribuables qui sont aussi des clients
évidemment mais la définition du service
public c'est qu'on doit être capable
aussi de tenir compte des zones qui sont
moins bien desservis ou qui sont plus
retirés c'est ça le service public est
fondamentalement nous sommes une
entreprise de service public qui veut
être utile aux français et donc même si
je dirais le des cours dès que le
discours d'économie des transports
tendrait à affecter les deniers vers le
réseau qu'est le plus parcourus nous
souhaitons malgré tout avoir une
attention très soutenue pour la logique
des territoires et donc avoir une
attention aux lignes de desserte fils du
territoire est bouillant points 5 vous
avez fait le parallélisme entre le
contrat de performance et le contrat cdg
c'est quand même deux contrats très
différent dans la mesure où le contrat
cdg
un contrat d'objectifs très spécifique
pour réaliser un projet le contrat de
performance est un contrat beaucoup plus
globale et qui a en plus à des clauses
de revoyure puisque c'est un contrat qui
porte sur une période de dix ans mais
qui est revolving alors par des mois
pardonnez moi pour mon mauvais français
mais c'est donc revu tous les trois ans
sur une période de 10 ans et donc là
l'idée n'est bien entendu pas de ne pas
respecter les clauses du contrat
performance en cours mais il est en
discussion c'est très différent de la de
la discussion où on voit en tout cas
pardon de l'a22 du contrat charles de
gaulle express et puis par rapport aux
personnels et aux co vide et bien le
salaire des cheminots il a été maintenu
pendant toute la période avec les
éléments de variables or contre un
terrain donc nous sommes dans une
situation qui pour l'instant est
stabilisé à cet égard est évidemment en
dialogue permanent avec les
organisations qui représente le
personnel voyage voilà monsieur le
président pour les éléments
complémentaires de réponse que je
pouvais apporter
merci monsieur le président je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de reprendre la parole
sur la question de la gouvernance quand
même la question de la gouvernance a été
un point très important du débat
parlementaire et j'y reviens pelouse est
dit les textes rien que les textes et à
les textes et aussi la volonté du
législateur et dans les débats qu'on a
eu on a bien souligné le fait qu'il ne
pouvait pas y avoir d'ouverture à la
concurrence sans une réelle autonomie d
cncf réseau et nous avions d'ailleurs eu
l'engagement et vous n'y êtes pour rien
notamment que nous aurions des
représentants du parlement au sein des
instances dirigeantes de sncf réseau
cet engagement du gouvernement n'a pas
été tenue on nous a promis à défaut
qu'on serait dans un vague comité des
partis qui n'est d'ailleurs toujours pas
constitué
vous avez également dit que nous avions
un régulateur très puissant et je me
félicite et je crois que mes collègues
le font avec moi de la qualité et du
travail qui est effectué et
effectivement par l'art affaire devenue
la rt mais il ne sert à rien qu'il émet
des recommandations si le gouvernement
s'assoit dessus
et dieu sait que sur la question
notamment de l'autonomie
il y ait eu des remarques très sévère
que nous avons repris à notre compte en
commission quant aux fameuses ordonnance
sur la gouvernance lesquels ordonnance
sur la gouvernance de v et là aussi nous
avions un engagement très ferme du
gouvernement devait être débattu au
parlement pour qu'on puisse vérifier
l'adéquation entre l'objectif
d'autonomie et les moyens mis en oeuvre
le débat n'a jamais eu lieu
donc vous n'y êtes pour rien c'est le
gouvernement qui une fois de plus a
failli a manqué à sa parole sur le sujet
mais je ne peux pas rester sans réagir
quand j'entends dire que finalement en
ce qui concerne la l'autonomie des
scènes cf réseau le compte serait on en
extrait pour notre nom malheureusement
on a été je vais pas dire qu'on a été
roulé dans la farine
mais je le pense vraiment vous n'y êtes
pour rien mais je tenais à le dire parce
que vraiment c'est une énorme déception
de ce texte sur lequel on s'est beaucoup
impliqué avec le rapporteur didier
mandelli et que l'ensemble des collègues
qui sont là ce soir est vraiment sur la
question de l'autonomie qui est
indispensable à une véritable ouverture
à la concurrence
on a plus que les cinq études je le
souhaitais le rappeler monsieur gontard
merci monsieur le président messieurs le
pdg d cncf réseau devrait d'abord saluer
le travail et l'implication des équipes
de sncf réseau pendant cette période
comprendre les difficultés liées à la
crise sanitaire durant la période de
confinement la sncf a adopté un plan
extrêmement réduite circulation et une
quasi arrêt des travaux il y aujourd'hui
forcément des inquiétudes sur la reprise
et un retour rapide à la normale
si je prends un exemple que je connais
bien avec l'étoile ferroviaire
grenobloise des travaux avait été
avait enfin été programmées avec des
financements est à région que ce soit
sur grenoble lyon grenoble rennes et
donc vous avez déjà répondu de manière
générale mais si vous pouviez repréciser
en fait comment vous allez prioriser le
redémarrage de ces travaux pouvez-vous
nous assurer que l'ensemble des travaux
programmés avant la crise seront bien
maintenu et avez-vous clairement les
capacités de faire face à ce décalage
sans remettre en cause des projets déjà
validés et puis de manière plus générale
ça déjà été c'est déjà été rappelés mais
le ministre et barry avait annoncé lors
de la présentation du rapport philizot
que des négociations avaient lieu avec
les régions sur les fameuses
classification des lignes du quotidien
des fameuses lignes 8,7 à 8,9 avec une
canalisation sncf un état région état ou
100% région dépend que des plans
d'action ont été signés avec certaines
certaines régions voulais savoir si vous
pouviez nous dira un petit peu ou en été
ces négociations et plus
particulièrement si vous aviez des
éléments sur les discussions avec la
région aura et puis une question sur la
sur les trains de nuit
il reste actuellement deux lignes
intérieures en train de nuit c'est
pourtant une alternative on le sait
efficace au transport aérien est un
moyen d enclavement le train de nuit
fait-il donc partie de vos priorités je
pense notamment à la continuité des
décisions puisque on a souvent cette
cette problématique pour pouvoir
maintenir les trains de nuit et pouvez
vous nous confirmer la reprise de la
circulation du paris briançon
dès le mois de juillet puisque c'est une
annonce qui a été faite mais j'aimerais
que vous pouviez nous l'a confirmé
et puis pour terminer nous payons
aujourd'hui une politique d' absence
d'entretien des lignes vous en avez un
petit peu parlé avec des renards des
rénovations complètes souvent plus
coûteuse est importante pour le maintien
du trafic donc et il envisager de revoir
cette doctrine avec des entretiens plus
réguliers et dans ce sens concernant
l'aspect environnemental vous étiez
engagé à trouver une alternative au
glyphosate sous un an je crois après la
loi la loi la baie dont vous pouvez vous
nous donner des échéances et la méthode
retenue pour ces alternatives au
glyphosate sur l'entretien des voies
merci monsieur gontard monsieur de
nicolay mais un merci monsieur le
président
monsieur le président mais mes questions
vont être un peu dans le sens de notre
collègue gontard et et chevrollier la
première c'est sur ces contrats de entre
la sncf réseau et la région ministre en
effet nous a annoncé que dans certains
cas c'est sncf réseau qui reprenait à
100% les lignes secondaires pas si on
peut les appeler l'iran des lignes
plutôt régionale et d'autres dans
d'autres cas c'était avec une convention
notamment ceux la ligne 1 caen alençon
le mans tours le ministre nous a dit que
normalement sncf réseau devrait
reprendre à 100% cette ligne si c'était
le cas lorsqu'il avait alors qu'il y
avait des discussions qui était engagé
avec les régions est-ce que les
calendriers de réfection de la ligne qui
est absolument nécessaire auront lieu
dans les temps voulus ou s'il faut aussi
il faut attendre encore plus c'est ma
deuxième question qui rejoint celle de
guillaume chevrollier sur les nuisances
l'année prochaine ça sera l'année
européenne du rail d'après ce que
comprendre que le problème
environnemental et notamment le problème
des nuisances sonores sur les lignes à
grande vitesse et août avec l'ouverture
à la concurrence sera probablement
abordée est-ce que d'ici là je l'espère
la sncf réseau aura trouvé des solutions
pour permettre aux riverains qui ont été
je le reconnais pas en deux mois et demi
extrêmement agréablement surpris du
calme qui existait sur ses rapports de
ces lignes mais ce que c'est entre ces
réseaux réfléchir notamment à des
protections environnementales de ces
lignes à grande vitesse merci merci
monsieur gilles et ça marche très bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général à la lecture
des écoutes des différentes questions et
de vos réponses
on peut quand même être relativement
inquiet par rapport à l' approche
budgétaire parce que j'ai le sentiment
qu'on est encore dans le monde d'avant
puisque quelque part quand vous parlez
du pacte ferroviaire vous soulignez que
vous êtes inscrit bien sûr dans le cas
des objectifs mais que vous attendez une
éventuelle révision à moyen terme mais
qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de vision
stratégique compte tenu des nouvelles
contraintes imposées bien évidemment par
la crise duco vide
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir donc une diminution très
importante des recettes vos clients les
compagnies clientes
aujourd'hui seront particulièrement
affaibli donc cette diminution de
recettes sera particulièrement
importante vous soulignez aujourd'hui
votre politique des moyens vous permet
tout juste de maintenir en fait à niveau
un ensemble d'équipements donc
l'ambition que nous pourrions attendre
aujourd'hui sera forcément
particulièrement limité sur ce plan
d'ailleurs par rapport aux questions de
michel vaspart vous êtes resté très
évasif par rapport à une approche plus
stratégique en termes de développement
de l'intermodalité et notamment
notamment les moyens qui prêts accordés
pour améliorer la qualité logistique du
réseau aujourd'hui avec les couplages
que nous pourrions attendre notamment au
niveau des ports et des ports maritimes
donc vous resté très évasif sur ces
sujets là on ne vois pas quels sont les
objectifs et la stratégie à court et
moyen terme
en d'autres termes il n'ya pas
aujourd'hui il me semble une vision
véritablement prospective au travers de
la crise des grandes difficultés
financières que vous allez vivre et que
vous subissez déjà en partie donc est ce
que vous pouvez m'éclairer sur ces
différents points d'eau merci monsieur j
je propose de répondre à ces trois
questions
ces trois interventions plus tôt
alors monsieur bontin donc comment
comment on va prioriser prioriser le
redémarrage des travaux
en réalité cette priorisation a déjà eu
lieu est en cours d'exécution
on a pendant la crise qu vite on a
utilisé le temps d'un arrêt assez
important des trafics voyageurs
essentiellement pour très rapidement
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on allait
redémarrer prioriser les chantiers on a
on avait fixé quatre catégories pour
redémarrer ses chantiers la catégorie la
plus prioritaire étant celles qui
permettent de continuer à acheminer les
trains stratégique d'approvisionnement
du territoire donc les trains fret y
compris pendant la crise qu vite et la
catégorie là entre guillemets la moins
prioritaire je rappelais qu'on était en
pleine crise que vite la catégorie la
moins prioritaire c'était le redémarrage
des très grands chantiers d'extension de
capacité parce que ces chantiers là ne
touchait pas je dirais le client du
quotidien ni le ni le client stratégique
donc sur la priorisation du redémarrage
des travaux en fait c'est tous ces
chantiers ont été à l'heure où nous
parlons redémarrer je vous ai indiqué
dans mon introduction que à date
85% des chantiers ont redémarré et on
sera à 100% donc de nouveau en pleine
capacité de travaux au grand plus tard
fin juin
et donc si on regarde non seulement les
travaux mais aussi la réouverture du
réseau on avait pris l'engagement que
dans les 48 heures
la date du début de déconfinement le
réseau structurant serait entièrement ré
ouvert et ça a été le cas et je dirais
dans la semaine plus de 80% des lignes
de desserte fine du territoire était
également ré ouverte et plus dans le
mois la quasi totalité a été réouvert
donc cette priorisation on a on a reçu
je dois vous dire les équipes ont reçu
pas mal de remontées positives de la
part de nos clients donc on pense que ce
cette stratégie de déconfinement hamad a
donné lieu à une satisfaction de nos
clients
alors un un bémol là dessus c'est
évidemment que nos clients fret qui ont
eu la liberté entre guillemets de
circuler avec un trafic voyageurs qui
étaient extraordinairement réduit la
qualité des sillons fred par voie
d'entraînement était exceptionnel
pendant pendant ces deux mois et demi et
la difficulté qu'on a pour l'instant
c'est de je dirais de continuer à
satisfaire les clients fret avec un
trafic voyageur évidemment qui
maintenant a déjà redémarré à plus de
50% et qui va être ramené en régime de
croisière dans les prochaines semaines
alors sur la capacité de certains
projets à être réalisés mais je pense en
fait sur ce sujet que la crise coville a
été simplement une séquence de deux mois
deux mois et demi pendant laquelle
l'exécution des projets a été retardé
notre volonté vraiment très affirmée et
que c'est le programme 2020 des travaux
et chantiers soient réalisés avec la
limitation que je viens d'indiquer en
réponse à une autre question
c'est à dire que pour les chantiers le
budget 2027 pas tellement la limite
budgétaire qui compte c'est surtout en
fait la capacité de reprogrammer
certains travaux sur des séquences
horaires qui ne dérange pas les clients
voyageurs ni les clients fret
alors vous avez évoqué la question des
discussions avec la région aura
moi je voudrais vous vous y répondre de
manière globale dans la stratégie qui
est menée par le groupe très conceptuel
sur les régions c'est à dire qu'ils les
territoires est une vraiment une des
toutes grandes priorités du groupe sncf
et de sncf réseau on a réclamé
immédiatement dès la nouvelle
gouvernance un dialogue intense avec les
régions non seulement au travers de
régions de france et en particulier la
commission mobilité des régions de
france mais aussi dans un dans un
contact personnel alors pour l'instant
sa distance yale ainsi en digital je
suis occupé à faire le tour je dirais d
président et des vice présidents de
région et dans la nouvelle stratégie de
sncf rezzouki ce qui devrait être prête
d'ici la fin de l'année
il y aura un volet territorial et
stratégies ferroviaire régional
important donc pour la partie
infrastructure qui sera spécifiquement
traités dans ce plan dans ce plan
stratégique sur les circulations paris
briançon je vais pas vous répondre parce
que c'est surtout en fait un sujet
d'opérateurs ferroviaires donc je
préfère ne pas m'exprimer à leur place
et il s'agissant des alternatives au
glyphosate bon je vais pas vous
embarquer dans de grandes discussions
techniques les alternatives au
glyphosate
la difficulté c'est que tant sur le plan
de la mise en oeuvre les techniques de
mise en oeuvre que sur le plan des
produits qui sont utilisés ça représente
des surcoûts très importants
alors évidemment comme nous voulons nous
inscrire pleinement dans la stratégie de
transition écologique du gouvernement
on va évidemment à se plaindre de
mesures qui ont été prises en cette
matière mais par contre les contraintes
et les surcoûts très très important que
ça donne pour l'entretien et la
maintenance d'un réseau qui je le
rappelle fait près de 4
puis 1000 km de voies ça a des
conséquences qu'il est impossible
d'absorber sur les finances propres de
l'entreprise
aucun programme de productivité qui peut
absorber des surcoûts d'une telle nature
et donc là l'enjeu c'est de voir comment
est ce que ces surcoûts vont être
financés vous pouvez nous donner une
idée du montant de ces surcoûts de son
du nommé général on fermerait sa part
par écrit parce que je voudrais être sûr
de ne pas me tromper
c'est plus de 100 millions d'euros en
tout cas en base annuelle alors sur sur
[Musique]
ce que j'ai moi ma distraction
on me dit si que pour paris briançon
il y aurait confirmation pour la reprise
en juillet mais encore une fois je
préfère ne pas ne pas m'exprimer à la
place la place deux de mes collègues
donc je pense que c'est mieux de leur
poser la question alors sur la
protection environnementale des lignes à
grande vitesse
oui évidemment on va faire le maximum de
ce qui est ce qui est possible de faire
c'est une réponse à la question de
monsieur nicolas et sur le les contrats
réseau sncf région en exécution des
lignes de desserte fine du territoire
alors à l'heure actuelle ce sont surtout
des conventions qui lient le
gouvernement avec les régions concernées
sur une ou deux lignes on est occupé à
réfléchir au financement mais pour le
reste la discussion sur le financement
est en cours donc je peux pas vous
donner malheureusement à l'heure
actuelle plus de détails là dessus
et puis alors monsieur gillet vous vous
interrogez sur la nouvelle vision
stratégique post co vide alors on est
occupé on est en fait dans une dans une
séquence qui est un petit peu compliqué
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi mon
prédécesseur a mis en place un
un plan stratégique qui s'appelle
nouvelair donc il a sûrement eu
l'occasion de vous parler ici en
commission c'est un plan qui est en fait
un plan qui vise l'industrialisation des
activités de sncf réseau et qui étaient
conçus à une époque où il n'y avait pas
encore les textes sur l'organisation du
groupe sncf
donc on était dans un contexte des pics
sncf réseau et d'autre part où on ne
sait pas ce que nous savons aujourd'hui
sur les implications de la crise qu vite
la grève qu'avec de très lourds impacts
qui a eu lieu en décembre janvier est
donc ce que je suis occupé à faire avec
l'équipe c'est de penser à un nouveau
plan stratégique d'ici la fin de l'année
qui préservent les acquis industrielle
de nouvelair et qui ajoute un certain
nombre de dimensions notamment sur
l'humanisation de l'entreprise qui
intègre aussi un certain nombre de
contraintes qui n'était pas prévisible
à l'époque on parle de deux ans deux ans
et demi et qui insère aussi pour la
partie non liées aux fonctions
essentielles ou aux décisions
d'investissement qui s'intègre de
manière élégante où tout en préservant
l'indépendance de sncf réseau à une
dynamique du groupe sncf et donc cette
nouvelle vision stratégique s'est pas
seulement poste que vite en fait on
était le premier jour je suis arrivée
sncf réseau début mars j'ai directement
pensé avec avec l'équipe
et entre temps le fait neuf séquelles et
intégrera évidemment les les effets de
la crise qu vide et ben j'espère avoir
le plaisir de vous de vous présenter ça
monsieur le président d'ici à la fin de
l'année ou au grand plus tard début
début 2021
donc vous éclairer sur la stratégie
post crise je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y
aura de très grandes inflexion
stratégique à proprement parler par
contre il y aura peut-être je le
souhaite dans le bon sens des inflexions
désinfection budgétaire qui permettront
de donner de la puissance et de
l'intensité à cette stratégie de
mobilité ferroviaire merci beaucoup
dernière question monsieur dantec dont
je serais étonné qu'il ne revienne pas
sur le glyphosate
oui merci monsieur le président
peut-être en commentaire je trouve 100
millions d'euros pour se passer du
glyphosate c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent donc je crois
qu on sera curieux de comprendre comment
vous chiffrer un tel surcoût alors qu'on
demande à l'ensemble des acteurs et
comme c'est comme piloter la sortie du
glyphosate dans une grande ville on
était quand même pas sur des surcoûts
pareil donc donc je serai curieux de du
détail de votre calcul sur un tel
surcoût mais je crois que on est quand
même tous conscients qu'il faudra un
moment sortir du glyphosate
je pense que vous avez entendu le
message de l'état et de la société par
rapport à ce que vous venez dire sur la
sur la stratégie
donc on entend bien qu'on vous
auditionne un peu tôt mais du coup vous
entendrez nos messages et vous venez de
le dire finalement il ya peut-être des
opportunités liées à la crise qu vide
comme dans chaque crise et notamment
peut-être de l'argent disponible pour le
fret
puisqu'on voit bien que l'on jeu climat
n'a pas été oublié cette fois ci en tout
cas au moins dans les discours par les
grands dirigeants européens sur la sur
les politiques de sortie de crise qu'on
a obligatoirement si on veut tenir nos
objectifs climat a ramené vers le rail
une partie du fret un routier nous le
disons d'intervention en intervention et
donc ma question serait de savoir si
dans ce plan que vous préparez vous
intégrez peut-être des opportunités de
financement nouvelles berry bce de
l'argent à pas cher war se rapprochant
du taux zéro avec du coude et des temps
d'amortissement extrêmement long des 50
60 ans qui permettraient et ça fait et
compris et qu est ce que disait michel
vaspart au début le fait de mettre sur
la table une stratégie d'infrastructure
fret cohérente avec les ports avec les
les grandes radial notamment la
traversée entre le nord et le sud de
l'europe
est-ce que ça c'est dans votre réflexion
aujourd'hui y compris dans la dans
l'analyse des opportunités de
financements nouveaux qui pourraient
venir dans le plan de relance européen
merci beaucoup
avant de vous laisser répondre à
monsieur dantec j'aimerais quand même
revenir un instant sur le coût de la
crise sur scène cf réseau parce que vous
nous avez dit que vous pouviez pas nous
donner de chiffres je n'ose imaginer que
le président d'une entreprise comme
réseau comme la sncf réseau n'est pas la
moindre idée de l'impact financier de la
crise qu vide près de trois mois après
son déclenchement
ce fardeau et parler de 2 milliards
quand on a reçu début mai sur l'ensemble
du groupe
qu'est ce que ça représente sur réseau
donnez-nous n'ont pas n'ont pas un
chiffre à la virgule près mais donnez
nous un ordre de grandeur
je crois que la représentation nationale
peut être informé le grand nord de
grandeur et pour vous expliquer pourquoi
est ce que ce chiffre n'est ni stabilisé
ni définitif c'est parce qu'on a on
calcule un impact qui tient compte donc
impact sur l'année 2020 2021 et 2022
puis il ya énormément de facteurs qui
jouent et notamment l'alimentation du
fameux fonds de concours qui lui même
l'alimentation du fonds de concours
repose sur les dividendes qui peuvent
être réalisés par l'activité voyageurs
et en particulier l'activité tgv
dividendes qui vous vous en doutez
risque de s'écraser vue là là
le noeud très faible niveau d'activité
voyageurs pendant ces deux mois alors ce
cet impact cumulé sur l'année 2020 2021
et 2022 jeunes expriment avec prudence à
certains hypothèse de retrouver un
niveau à 100 % le trafic voyageurs il
est évalué pour l'instant entre 700 et
800 millions d'euros
one shot ça veut dire quoi one shot ça
veut dire que quand on appris les faits
en 2020 en 2021 et en 2022
mais après on a retrouvé le niveau
j'espère normal des circulations des
circulations voyageurs et au fait à ce
moment-là c'est un impact il se traduira
dans les comptes annuels de l'entreprise
pour ses années avec un impact cumulé
sur la dette
en dehors de cela et ça c'est pas c'est
pas lié à la crise qu vite
indépendamment de la reprise de la dette
en deux phases au 1er janvier 2020 et au
1er janvier 2022
on est plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros à côté de l'objectif de
stabilisation du cash flow de
l'entreprise en 2024 et donc monsieur le
président même si ces chiffres reposent
sur certaines hypothèses
et même si je m'exprime avec prudence
parce que il ya encore aussi il ya des
effets positifs et des effets négatifs
là dedans simplement je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur le fait que la
situation financière de sncf réseau par
rapport à un équilibre on est très très
très loin de compte et que donc il
faudra des discussions intenses et une
force de conviction que j'espère la plus
persuasive possible pour faire en sorte
que les arbitrages réalisés se
traduisent par des suppléments de
financement et pas par des réductions de
fonctionnalités du réseau alors par
rapport à la question donc juste pour
bien comprendre ce présent vous êtes en
train de nous dire que l'objectif
d'équilibré financier en 2024 ne sera
pas atteint ah non ça je ne vous ai pas
dit parce que
depuis le passage en société anonyme
et ça c'est un élément de réponse que je
voulais apporter à une des questions de
monsieur dantec qui parle de l'argent à
taux zéro tout ça fait partie d'une
grande équation qui a changé il ya deux
ans parce que il y a environ deux ans
eurostat qui est l'organisme européen
qui s'occupe de la classification de
l'est du contrôle et de l'établissement
des comptes publiques des états
européens
eurostat a décidé pour tous les pays
membres que le périmètre financier des
gestionnaires d'infrastructures en
europe seraient consolidées avec le
périmètre des finances publiques des
états concernés c'est cette décision là
un impact tout à fait majeur sur la
politique d'investissement qu'on peut
avoir je vais vous citer un exemple tout
de suite d'une part et d'autre part bien
entendu sur la manière avec laquelle
l'état français dans ce cas ci mais les
états partout en europe
regarde les comptes du gestionnaire
d'infrastructure alors je vous donne un
exemple dans mon ancienne vie avec toute
une équipe de management on est parvenu
en 12 ans à réduire le nombre de postes
d'aiguillage de 365 à une à une dizaine
ce qui a permis de réaliser des gains de
productivité vraiment substantielle mais
pour faire ça il faut bien entendu
amorcer la pompe de l'investissement
concentrer les postes d'aiguillage qui
était un des deux grands projets que je
souhaiterais lancé pour la
rationalisation de l'outil industriel du
réseau français vous démarrez les trois
ou quatre premières années avec pompe
énormément dans le cash flow parce qu'il
faut construire de nouveaux bâtiments il
faut concentrer les installations faut
déplacer des câbles voir remonter des
câbles de signalisation alors que vous
avez plus de quinze mille trains qui
circulent tous les jours en france
donc ce sont des investissements
gigantesques qui sont productifs à
condition qu'on soit d'accord d'investir
au début les trois quatre premières
années sans en voir les effets positifs
et peu après les cash flow négatif que
vous avez au début de la courbe
trois quatre ans ils commencent les
effets positifs commencent à se faire
sentir
et puis sur les années qui suivent
jusqu'à 40 50 ans j'irai jusqu'à 2 vitam
aeternam quand vous avez fait un projet
pareil vous en recul y est les bénéfices
parce qu'évidemment le personnel qui
travaille dans ses fonctions de contrôle
de trafic
ils le font de manière beaucoup plus
centralisée ce n'est pas qu'ils
travaillent plus travaillent de manière
beaucoup plus efficace parce qu'on leur
a mis un outil industriel qui est
beaucoup plus efficace entre entre les
mains mais donc dans la mesure où
maintenant eurostat consolide tout ce
qui a été fait dans mon ancienne vie
c'est à dire de pouvoir dépenser de
réaliser ces investissements sur fonds
propres en faisant un peu de dettes au
départ est bouillant récupérant et bien
c'est plus possible sauf si évidemment
l'état et en particulier dans ces états
européens le ministre qui est chargée
des comptes publics est d'accord d'avoir
cet effet un peu de bulle de dette
transitoire et puis dans d'en recueillir
les bénéfices et donc je relis à votre
votre question monsieur dans le tech à
savoir argent à taux zéro en réalité
aujourd'hui le taux d'intérêt implicite
sur la dette de la sncf réseau qui est
aujourd'hui gérée au niveau de la maison
mère
il est déjà relativement bas donc en
fait ce n'est pas une question vraiment
de charges financières même si tant que
c'est pas zéro ça pèse évidemment sur
les comptes
metz mais c'est qu'une dette même quand
elle est à taux zéro caractéristiques
d'une dette c'est qu'elle doit quand
même être remboursés et c'est ça le
noeud du problème c'est comment trouver
les ressources pour rembourser la dette
et donc moi je dirais simplifions le
schéma puisque de toute façon toutes les
dépenses qui sont faites au sein de sncf
réseau aujourd'hui sont consolidés dans
le périmètre des finances publiques de
l'état
le sujet n'est plus tellement un sujet
d'endettement ou de désendettement de
sncf réseau de dépenses sncf réseau le
sujet c'est un sujet
de quels transferts d'argent sur une
base annuelle
l'état veut bien ou ne veut pas bien
faire pour
pour sncf réseau puisque en réalité les
faits sur les finances publiques est à
peu près comparable j'ai du coup en
complément j'ai bien compris le montage
financier mais est ce que vous êtes en
capacité compris technique de mettre sur
la table dans la discussion avec l'état
un projet de développement cohérent à
l'échelle nationale du fret ferroviaire
avec les infrastructures lourdes qui
manquent sur les ports et en transversal
est ce qu'aujourd'hui techniquement
c'est un projet que vous pourriez mettre
sur la dame alors le le le pardonnez moi
j'avais mal compris le cette question là
le sujet de l'investissement pour le
fret ferroviaire est un sujet tout à
fait spécifique et là la question
stratégique qu'il faut se poser cette
quand on a un réseau qui est déjà en
aussi mauvais état dans sa partie la
moins fréquentée mais aussi une partie
du réseau structurant la question qui se
pose et ça fait partie du dialogue qu'on
a avec l'état est ce que il n'est pas
préférable de mettre les rares deniers
disponibles dans la partie du réseau qui
sert tout le monde et pas uniquement
dans une partie spécifique
je pose la question mais pour revenir
sur donc sur la question de
l'endettement et du fonctionnement du
cycle financier en réalité qu on
s'endette un peu plus on consent des
temps un peu moins c'est surtout un
sujet d' équilibre de liquidité et de
solvabilité de la société anonyme sncf
réseau rapport aux finances publiques
l'effet de verser un subside ou de
laisser s'endetter il est à quelques à
quelques spécificités techniques près
environ en pardon à peu près équivalent
alors sur les opportunités qui sont
générées par la crise qu vide je suis je
suis comme vous je suis dans un dans une
situation d'espoir les détails sur les
surcoûts du glyphosate vous seront bien
entendu fourni et je crois monsieur en
tout cas monsieur le président j'espère
avoir répondu à votre coeur et votre
question sur les l'impact financier de
la crise qu vide
merci monsieur le président d'avoir
apporté ces éléments c'est vrai que
demeure néanmoins beaucoup de beaucoup
d'interrogations et beaucoup
d'inquiétude donc je pense qu'on aura
certainement l'occasion de vous
auditionnés à nouveau et qu'on a
toujours cette inquiétude par rapport
aux conséquences financières par rapport
aux conséquences sur le programme
d'investissement par rapport à un
certain nombre de sujets comme cela et
notamment les petites lignes qui sont
des sujets extrêmement important on sait
tous dans quel état est le réseau
ferroviaire on ne voudrait pas que il y
ait un dd recule encore par rapport au
programme de régénération
on voudrait pas non plus que les efforts
qui ont été faits que l'on parle et avec
la reprise de la dette ne permettent pas
d'atteindre des objectifs en termes de
daikin financiers donc beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions auxquelles
évidemment il est pas encore principe
sans doute de répondre en totalité donc
on espère que dans les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois on pourra en
savoir davantage
merci en tout cas devoir participer à
cette audition voilà pour l'audition de
luc lallemand devant la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable du sénat le pdg de
sncf réseau qui appelle notamment l'état
investir pour l'entretien et la
rénovation du réseau ferroviaire
vous pouvez retrouver notre article sur
cette audition sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr on vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur notre antenne